please allow me to be the first and
perhaps at this point the only person to
wish you a happy columbus day well i'm
not the only one we have some other
columbus fans here at the daily wire and
there are more scattered throughout the
country but the number of people who
will acknowledge and show proper
appreciation for columbus or any other
of the the heroes of western
civilization
is dwindling rapidly more and more our
country is overrun by historically
illiterate halfwits who insist that we
cannot celebrate the great men of our
history because those great historical
men
made the mistake of being historical
rather than modern what's more they
committed the crime of being mere men
and not angels they had flaws they were
not perfect and if they weren't perfect
then they were scum and all of their
achievements were dirt and ash amounting
to nothing that's the popular modern
attitude anyway
and it's an attitude especially
prevalent in people who themselves have
never achieved a single thing of note at
all in their lives
they've never done anything of value in
their entire lives they've contributed
absolutely nothing to the world
whatsoever and yet they feel qualified
to scoff at the achievements of the
people who made their luxurious lives
possible
they don't even see the irony in mocking
columbus for his alleged navigational
deficiencies even as these same people
can't make it a half a mile to the
walgreens down the street without the
assistance of a satellite i mean they
need a satellite a phone a car just to
make it a half mile
all of the all of the the the technology
that the world can offer them they need
just just for that trip
christopher columbus navigating
completely uncharted waters half a
millennium ago
did not have those technological
advantages he had to make his way
through the mostly unknown sea
across thousands of treacherous miles
using the stars
and dead reckoning and other techniques
that would flummox his modern critics
all of whom would be shipwrecked in
about 45 minutes if they were in the
same situation
but columbus survived the first voyage
and discovered a whole part of the globe
that was unknown to his civilization at
the time
and this is when the modern losers again
chime in with one of the two or three
bits of information that they know about
this subject all of which they acquired
from twitter memes and they announced
that columbus he didn't even mean to
discover the americas he was trying to
find asia ha what a dope
yes of course columbus didn't mean to
discover the americas you idiots
nobody knew that it existed
how does that undermine the significance
of the discovery
if some future team of astronauts
accidentally discover a life-bearing
moon of jupiter on their way to i don't
know explore pluto
should we dismiss their groundbreaking
history shaping discovery on the basis
that they originally intended to make a
different groundbreaking history shaping
discovery
would you sit back here on earth on your
couch and say what a bunch of dorks they
were trying to find pluto and
accidentally discovered extraterrestrial
life instead
perhaps you would but that says more
about you than any of the explorers who
are out changing the world while you sit
on your fat ass injecting cheese whiz
straight into your veins
over the course of columbus's voyages he
discovered many caribbean islands and
explored the coasts of south and central
america he didn't make it to what is now
the continental united states but he
made it possible
for future explorers to soon find it
and that's quite an achievement i would
say
or must he be blamed for only
discovering half of the western
hemisphere while neglecting to discover
the other half
the point with columbus is that he was
one of the men one of the primary men
to bring civilization to this side of
the globe
he planted the seeds for the society
that we all live in today
if columbus never existed
your life would be very different in
fact your life you might not exist at
all yourself
and it would be different in a much
worse way
he was a great explorer
he was not a great governor or
administrator yes he also took slaves he
executed both spaniards and indians
under his rule
he uh took gold
he was not nearly as good at as leading
men on dry land as he was at leading men
while they were on the sea this was a
common flaw of explorers of that era
many of them were brilliant on their
ships but incompetent to even horrible
on solid ground magellan made it
three-quarters of the way around the
globe before getting himself killed in a
needless conflict with a tribe in the
philippines
see a certain type of man was needed to
navigate a fleet of ships across
uncharted waters
a different kind of man was needed to
manage settlements these are different
skills
but the thing is back in those days if
you were a captain of one of these ships
you had to be everything you had to play
all of these roles
you had to be an expert in in every
conceivable
area
unfortunately you know the latter type
the ones that were actually good at
managing settlements they had no way of
getting to the settlement except by
hitching a ride
with the former type and the former they
weren't often willing to seed control of
the land they had just gone through all
the trouble of discovering
that was the issue
now we can acknowledge these realities
while still honoring the achievements of
the people who shape the world we all
currently and most of us passively
occupy
here's the problem
if we're saying that the brutality and
violence of historical figures entirely
negates the good they did
and the things they achieved
then we've painted with a brush so broad
that it erases everyone and i mean
everyone
that's one of the things that makes the
push to replace columbus day with
indigenous people's day so incredibly
ridiculous
and that's a push that's almost
succeeded in fact joe biden on friday
became the first president in history to
issue an indigenous people's day
proclamation officially acknowledging
the holiday that is meant to replace
not only replace but be an apology for
columbus day
but the problem should be obvious
to anybody with an above room
temperature iq which which means that
it's not obvious to very many people
these days
if we cannot celebrate columbus day
because the european explorers and
settlers practice conquest and slavery
how can we celebrate indigenous peoples
day seeing how
indigenous people practice an even more
ruthless form of conquest and slavery
despite what you may have heard
europeans did not introduce these forms
of brutality to these shores
the indian tribes had already discovered
them for themselves and often took it
several steps farther
for example the most powerful tribes in
mesoamerica would take slaves and then
add the extra step of cutting their
beating hearts out of their chests and
sometimes consuming their carcasses
not all tribes had human sacrifice but
they all lived by the law of conquest if
you wanted land you took it if you
wanted to keep it you had to defend it
if you couldn't defend it your land
would be conquered
and among indians it also meant that
you're that part of conquering land if
your land was conquered it mean that it
meant that all of your men would be
tortured and killed
and your daughters would be taken as sex
slaves
that's just the way it worked that's the
way it worked everywhere among nearly
all indigenous people
if the europeans were land thieves
they were stealing from thieves
if they were conquerors they were
conquering conquerors
if they were killers they were killing
killers
does that make it all okay
not necessarily but it does complicate
the black and white it does complicate
sort of the black and white
victim versus oppressor model that we've
come up with in modern times
and it does also raise the question as
to why
we should celebrate one group of
oppressive conquerors the indians and
not the other
see once we understand historical
context
and we see that history was a brutal
time
filled with violent people and that
every inhabited inch of the globe has
been settled through war and every line
has been drawn in blood
once we see all of that the only
sensible thing is to accept that reality
and thank god that our reality is a
little bit less bleak than that a little
bit
less and then decide who to honor and
celebrate based on their achievements
see if we focus on sin
if that's the only thing we're thinking
about
there are no winners
no one is worthy if that's all we're
focusing on
and that's the case even today
but if we focus on achievement
if that's what we're looking
how does it all shake out
i mean are we celebrating indigenous
people's day because of their
achievements
is that holiday supplanting columbus day
because the achievements of indigenous
people were greater than columbus's
achievements
well if that's the case what were their
achievements exactly
and that's a sincere question
i'm not asking it rhetorically
what were their achievements
if you're asking me to celebrate
indigenous people's day what were the
achievements of these indigenous people
what am i celebrating exactly
am i just celebrating them for existing
is that the achievement
now we know that the native tribes were
about three or four thousand years
behind european civilization in terms of
technology art philosophy government
and in pretty much every other way
i mean
the most advanced civilizations in this
part of the world were building pyramids
the most advanced ones many other tribes
hadn't even discovered agriculture
so so what are we celebrating on
indigenous peoples day
i think the proclamation from joe biden
clears things up he writes in in general
terms by the contributions of native
tribes but he doesn't list any specific
ones and then he has this he says quote
the federal government has a solemn
obligation to lift up and invest in the
future of indigenous people and empower
tribal nations to govern their own
communities and make their own decisions
we must never forget the centuries-long
campaign of violence displacement
assimilation terror wrought upon native
communities and tribal nations
throughout our country today we
acknowledge the significant sacrifices
made by native people to this country
and recognize their many ongoing
contributions to our nation
uh okay so it's not really about
contributions
it's about victim status
because we don't honor achievements
anymore if we did columbus would still
have his holiday all to himself
instead we honor victimhood
even if the victims were victimizers
themselves
even so
all that matters is who can plant their
flag the highest up on victim mountain
that's what we're supposed to celebrate
today
and it's it's twisted and backwards and
perverse
it breeds a society of passive weaklings
seeking always to become victims
themselves because that's where the
power lies
that's where affirmation and celebration
lies that's that's where you gain it
and that's the society that we're
building rather than building a society
of bold and courageous people who admire
men for their accomplishments
and seek to achieve greatness themselves
see personally i prefer the latter
approach
and that is reason enough
among many other reasons
to say again
happy columbus day well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content